good morning we're extremely lucky today
have professor and a pile come and speak
with us now professor pile is an HHMI
investigator that's Howard Hughes
Medical Institute investigator and this
is an award that's given to only the top
scientists in the field and it really
means that she's extraordinarily special
and I think you'll get to see that today
she has a BA in chemistry from Princeton
University one of those other schools
from South a PhD in chemistry from
Columbia University another questionable
institution somewhere to the west of us
she's won an incredible number of awards
over the years besides being a Howard
Hughes Medical Investigator she was a
Cyril scholar Beckman young investigator
and there's many many more on this list
a National Science Foundation young
investigator award and so forth about an
impressive list of achievements but I
think what the most impressive thing is
is that she does really neat really
beautiful science that she can actually
explain to all of us today we're very
lucky to have her thanks so much for
that very nice introduction I think what
we're most lucky about is that there are
people like Aaron and Anissa who put
together things so science can be
visible to everybody and it doesn't
isn't just like the lucky few such as
myself who get to go into lab and have
all this fun every day you can see a
little taste of it I should also mention
about me just so you know because there
are a lot of kids in the audience I have
kids too so hopefully some of this talk
I'll tell you about has been helped by
the fact that they asked me lots of
questions Thomas is here he's nine and I
have twin girls who are six so that's
three and then all the neighbor kids so
so I'm pretty used to having kids around
and and and they would always helped me
explain thing okay so let's get
careful work to get this thing just
right and I yanked it off maybe
replicate it how's that okay it's kind
of like in a precarious position here
okay so so let let me explain what we're
going to do today here so we're going to
start off with a movie that was not made
by me it was funded by the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute and it was made by a
collaborative effort of scientists at
Harvard and it's really going to be it's
the beginning of a new kind of
revolution in animation that's the
result of a collaboration between
scientists and artists and so what
you're going to see is um is sort of the
function of a whole bunch of machines as
it as a cell changes shape and I'll tell
you a little bit more about what this
cell is doing in a second but just to
tell you a little bit more about the
film a lot of scientists like me we try
to solve the structures of biomolecules
so we can tell exactly what they look
like and how they look when they're in
different stages of motion but it
doesn't do much good to help people see
how they function unless an artist can
put it all into into sort of a film so
you can see them at work so in this
movie when you see it you'll notice that
you see molecules walking around that's
actually what they look like for the
most part because they're based on those
structures that scientists have solved
so this is a new thing that's wonderful
that's happening in science in the
artists and scientists are working
together to help us communicate better
so the movie you'll see here is about
what happens in a white blood cell when
the cells surrounding it the skin cells
tell it we have to go on red alert
because there's an infection and the
white blood cell is the SWAT team of the
body it goes out to combat germs that
get in us and what you're going to see
are all the machines and motors inside
the white blood cell that help get it
ready to go out and fight okay so i will
try and relate some of the changes
although i'm not a cell biologist you
heard I was a cab
which is true but in any case i will try
to relate some of the things that are
going on as the movie goes but mostly
just enjoy the film
do you have sound
you guys can't hear the sound okay well
you know what I'm going to try again see
if I crank it up on my computer if you
can hear it if the system here it's just
that it's my computer making it
problematic
is the system here plugged into this you
can hear
okay so what's happened here actually
we're going to do is we're going to back
all the way up okay
so here's a white blood cell and it's in
contact with the skin cell and it's
getting the skin cell is sending it a
message through these molecules telling
it time to get ready to gear up to fight
an infection and they're talking through
those molecules and they send the signal
along a cell membrane on those rafts
these are molecules involved in
signaling sending the messages between
the cells and they're getting
transported along and through the
skeleton of a cell this is sort of the
membrane skeleton on the outside this is
part of the cellular cytoskeleton as we
go inside the cell it's made of these
protein filaments and one thing that
white blood cell has to do is change its
shape to combat infection and here it's
making these special skeletal structures
to change its shape it's got a break old
structures and build new ones it's
building highways for motor proteins to
transport molecules to the its surface
and these are the cargo motors we're
going to be seeing them in great detail
in this talk and they transport big
stuff from the inside of the cell to the
exterior and every time you see a little
blah be like that it's a cargo motor
moving along now the nucleus of the cell
sends out RNA and that's because this
cell to fight infection has to make some
new proteins so these ribosomal protein
factories load onto the RNA and they
start to make protein encoded by this
long loopy RNA some of these proteins
have to be taken to the mitochondria
this big lobby looking guys a
mitochondria and in that case the
ribosome actually makes the proteins and
stick them in the mitochondrial membrane
some of the proteins made in some of the
membranes of the cell have to be kept in
these giant bags to be exported to the
surface and those kinase and cargo
motors take it to this pool structure
called the Golgi and they get changed
that gets fused with the outer cell
membrane and all the contents of that
bag get dumped out and then we get these
special signaling molecules on the
surface here's the way blood cell here's
the skin cell they're going to talk now
this way now he's going to touch that
guy and send chemical signals to the
other cell and that tells the white
blood cell okay you're ready for action
now he's changing his shape with a bet
it's like sliding along this will help
him go through the cells between cells
and now he's ready to fight it and he's
in the blood stream ready to go to his
target hi so
so that's just a sort of get you set up
I I'm worried that the rest of chocolate
seemed so boring compared to that that's
so cool but there are animations of this
type throughout the talk now one of the
things that you guys probably picked up
on that is I think the coolest thing
about this film is the kinase and
molecules that are marching along
carrying the big bag right it looks like
something it looks like something out of
the Sorcerer's Apprentice that old
Disney movie and that's the kind of
motor will be talking about today in
fact he's going to be our first example
so today we're going to take three
different types of motor proteins and
we're going to describe them in detail
and the reason I like these is they're
not just molecules that just you know
sit there I like the study molecules
that walk shuffle spin and carry stuff
around and that's because as you saw in
the film ourselves are full of these
little nanomachines it's like they're
full of these robots and factories and
today if possible I'd like to give you a
flavor for how they work and probably
won't we won't get all the details but
if you just develop an interest in them
there's a lot more you can learn about
them so all the different kinds of
machines will discuss there are many
kinds in the cell but we don't we only
have a half an hour so we can talk about
three we've already seen an animation of
a cargo motor and I'll show you there
are several kinds some of them walk foot
over foot some of them shuffle and some
of them hop and I'll show you the
difference another beautiful kind of
motor that is fun to study our rotary
motors that spin and do work just like a
waterwheel and then the kind i
personally study our motors that instead
of tracking on that protein highway like
we saw in the movie they move on DNA or
RNA and they do different operations on
the DNA and those are called helicase so
we'll know try to take a look at all
three and in each case what I want to do
is show you an animation so you can sort
of see
with the molecule looks like when it's
in action then I want to see if I can
explain the way they work which I will
try to do but if it's confusing please
raise your hand and finally I think it's
very important that you all see real
experiments and real data demonstrating
how we study these molecules so you can
actually watch them and in each case
we'll be looking at single molecule
experiments because to look at molecular
motion we need at least two kinds of
information one we need to understand
the molecular structure and second we
need to be able to watch individual
molecules in action so we have to
develop ways to look at things that are
extremely small okay molecules are
really small it's very important before
we start for everybody to kind of get a
grip on that if we were to you know the
kinase and you saw marching along it
looks like a little person right if you
had as many kindnesses as there are
people in the United States and you were
to pack them together you still wouldn't
be able to see them I mean they're
really really tiny okay so we have to
come up with special methods and some of
our methods involve light and i'll show
you in some cases we put a big light on
the molecule that special cameras can
sense and in other cases we have lasers
that allow us to pull on them one at a
time and watch what they do so in each
case i'll try to show you a single
molecule experiment
all right our first category are the
cargo motors and these are nano machines
that walk on tracks and carry things
around and they also help to maintain
the cytoskeleton or overall architecture
of a cell there are three basic kinds of
cytoskeletal cargo motors kinesin dining
and myosin and they can look they like
to move things directionally did you
notice in the movie the kinase and
didn't just kind of go forward and then
back and then forward again now he
marched forward continuously and this is
one of the great mysteries that all of
us in the field are studying right now
how can a molecule have directional
motion from point A to point B how is
that accomplished and we're not totally
sure yet but that's one of the things
we're working on so to give you an
example here is a nerve cell that's
trying to grow out nerves can be very
long the nerves in our body can be a
meters long and to get molecules from
the cell body out to the part of the
nerve cell that's growing we have these
long tubulin fibers that we saw in the
movie those tracks and the kargil motors
kind even and dining carry things from
one part of the cell to the other the
kinase and move them this way now let's
look at our kinase and again remember we
saw him it's as if he has feet down here
in a body and little arms that carry all
kinds of stuff okay and carry them from
the cell body to the end of the cell now
once they get down here there's a
different motor with a different
polarity with respect to the track it
likes to go in the other direction and
his he's named dining um and you can see
dining looks totally different he had
the delicate little feet looks like he's
wearing you know fancy pants and he has
this like little tiny tether to his
cargo these have no similarity or very
little similarity structurally but they
they are partners in moving things
around so that's just sort of an example
of how
all that works a guy named Ron veil at
ucsf wrote a brilliant article that um
articulate it was actually called how
things move that was just the name of it
and he articulated that there are five
basic components in the cargo motor
toolbox five kinds of cargo motors that
I'm showing you here and the reason I'm
showing you them right now is so you can
see there they have a lot of
similarities but they have some
differences look how different dining
looks from KY Neeson who we've been
talking about but I like how he colored
these with the blue feet grey body in
the green carrying arms okay so
basically this is our toolkit in our
body for things that carry stuff around
and like all the motors will talk about
today they need fuel and they don't burn
gasoline they burn the bodies fuel which
is ATP adenosine triphosphate and it
looks like this okay this is a high
energy molecule that undergoes breakage
at this position and when it does so it
allows molecules to change confirmation
and actually Power movement indirectly
and I'll show you a little bit about how
that works in a minute so again from
Ron's article and I'll show you a movie
of Chinese and walking in a second
myosins standard myosins which are what
help move around things in our muscle
cells myosin is essential for the way
our muscles work like right now when I'm
doing this all these myosins are
actively doing their thing and myosins
have two feet but in conventional
myosins they're not using them both to
walk like this they hop on one and they
go directionally which is interesting
how that possibly works whereas kinase
and is using them both to actually walk
foot over foot or hand over hand and
there are yet other motors in the
helicase family that move forward not by
walking but by shuffling so one
it goes forward and then the other one
slides behind like that so all different
strategies for motion along a track are
utilized in biological systems by
molecules and they all use ATP to move
and do work and how do they do that just
one more word before we show some more
cute movies is that it's not that the
energy of ATP is magically converted
into heat and that's what powers these
molecules instead the reason ATP is the
fuel for these motors is that it's used
as a switch this kind even part down
here this little foot and ankle region
is the part that powers the movement and
the way it does that is that when this
part binds ATP the ankle is in this
configuration when the ATP is hydrolyzed
the structure changes in other words
when ATP is split into two pieces this
guy can't maintain this same structure
and he flips out and he assumes a new
structure and that flips this foot
forward and it plunks down in a new spot
okay so in fact instead of like our car
motor where energy is converted in a
different way these guys convert energy
by convert the energy in a chemical bond
by changing their conformation and
moving directionally or spinning
directionally okay that's enough of all
kinds of details here now let's see how
this works here's a kinase and it's
about to sit down on a microtubule the
foot sits it's in this confirmation it
binds an ATP burns it and that changes
the confirmation here which throws the
other foot forward it also changes its
affinity for the lattice or the highway
it's on the other foot stewing the same
thing and it's coordinating its motion
with this one so then this one can lie
down this one hydrolyzed already so he's
going to pick up soon and get flung
around and set down forward
okay now one thing we do know about
directional motion is that this tubulin
filament is not the same going forward
is backward as you'll probably notice
from the from the movie and from this
picture here it has a polarity okay this
molecule likes to have you could imagine
the stripes are kind of going
asymmetrically like this somehow this
molecule sense is that orientation of
the polymer and that helps it be
directional and go in the right
direction okay there's our guy again you
can watch him walk a little bit more
it's always fun so he binds an ATP he
hydrolyzes the neck changes conformation
and then the whole superstructure
changes in response and then the forward
foot is undergoing the same process
flinging the other foot forward etc and
this is an animation created by a
collaboration between Ron veil and
Graham Johnson I think Graham Johnson
was the artist who put all of this in
two pictures so we can see okay then I
promised you guys an experiment right so
you could actually see molecules in
motion and this is work done by a
colleague at Brandeis named Jeff Jeff
jealous and jeff did a cool thing he
took a kind even and he had it hold a
giant polystyrene bead okay this bead is
huge compared to the kinase it um but in
a Cell you in water in a cellular
environment it's almost like things feel
sort of weightless there isn't momentum
and wait in the same way that we feel it
in the microscopic world so it's not
like this big bead is going to crush mr.
Kenny's in here he's going to be it's
going to sort of float above him and the
kinesin is going to be able to walk even
though he's stuck carrying this massive
bead here's the bead and we can see it
in a
very very good camera and here's a track
of tubulin and what you're going to see
is a single molecule of kinase and
carrying this bead why do we do this so
that we can tell how fast kinase and
wants which is actually pretty fast now
I want you to see there's times when he
appears to pause we're going to talk
about that in a second most the time
he's motoring along pretty smoothly and
experiments like this help us to tell
all kinds of mechanical properties of
the molecule now i'm going to show you
another thing remember when i said ATP
is food for these guys they like it okay
they bind it they hydrolyze it and they
can keep walking as long as they have
enough ATP they keep going but remember
in the movie there are pauses and that's
because jeff did a dirty trick to this
kind even in addition to giving it some
ATP it's through in this yucky molecule
am PP NP which is known as an inhibitor
notice you can't cut it here that
linkage can't be cut by the kinesin so
the reason we saw pause is here and here
who is because occasionally the kinase
and didn't bind its favorite food it
bound this molecule and it stopped it
was like ah and then that molecule had
that had to leave before a good one
could bind and the kinase and could keep
going okay so one of the ways we study
molecules is to give them the food they
like and then occasionally give them
something yucky and see how they respond
to it and you can actually see that
process in this video so back up show to
you one more time
okay so he's happy he's eating oh I MPP
+ B yuck now he's going he paused for a
second and the time frames of all of
these processes tell us a lot about how
quickly these guys buying their energy
use it we get all kinds of information
from these movies okay so that was a
flavor of how we study directional
motors yeah yeah the real time for that
one it's hard to say because that's a
that's in a mixture of different
components but how fast kine Eason
actually tracks it's uh I yesterday I
was looking this up and the number
escapes me but if you think about how
it's tracking through a cell it's going
to get through an entire cell and I
think about a millisecond time scale so
they're moving quite quickly this is at
a scale that's hard to see because you
know of the translation of of
microscopic space to larger space so
rotary motors is our next topic and
these are neat because they don't go
forward they spin around okay and we use
rotary motors in our cells or many times
types of cells have clocks inside of
them and have all kinds of pumps and
things inside of them and most of them
in terms of their molecular structure
our rotary motors and one of the most
important examples of these is the f1 or
cf-18 epa's and this is a really
complicated slide and there's only a few
things I want you to take away from it
there's a rotary motor that stuck inside
the membrane of one of the cellular
compartments called the mitochondria and
it has a part that sort of sticks it in
the membrane it has a part in the center
that rotates just like the interior of a
waterwheel and
they're also there's the sort of
circular component that spins around
that within which there are a series of
chemical reactions that help us to
actually make ATP now remember I told
you that ATP is the fuel of the cell we
also have to make it we make it in our
mitochondria and um it's also
synthesized if you're a plant in your
chloroplasts and so it's actually made
in this rotating motor now this really
does function to some extent like a
water wheel but instead of water one of
the things that helps push it is a flow
of tiny tiny atoms called protons and in
a plant these are made during
photosynthesis there's a gradient of
protons that's made as the
photosynthetic molecules in a plant
split water into oxygen and protons
those flow then into the cell and out
through our special machine ATP synthase
alright and we're going to look at the
structure of this and how it spins in a
second but just so you see how it works
you can get the same effect whenever you
have a paddle or a sort of a pinwheel
structure in a flow of water where the
water comes in sort of toward the bottom
and leaves toward the top of a tube okay
or of a container so the the way that an
ATP a since sits inside the membrane is
very much like this vortex power plant
that has a waterwheel in it so we
actually know the molecular structure of
the parts of this pump and this is the
internal part that moves and spins
around and then this series of six
molecules assemble so each one of these
is a separate protein and they assemble
to make this beautiful donut and inside
the donut is this long thing that's
going to be the thing rotating inside
and every time he rotates and faces one
of these
sets of red and yellow molecules it
squishes the starting materials for the
ATP together so in other words ATP is
made up of some smaller parts and to get
the ATP to get made for all those parts
to come together this machine basically
squishes them together with force okay
so basically it's throwing phosphate and
the dentist seen diphosphate together
into this space smashing them together
and it makes ATP and then we use that
okay so you're going to see how this
works in the next video this is the
rotation we're looking at the top of ATP
synthase now as it rotates and this is
the internal rotating component and you
see it goes at about 120 degrees with
each rotation squishing the parts into
the face of these and making a molecule
every time okay so for every full
rotation it's going to make three atps
see how its symmetry is such that it
would make three rather than six okay so
you're seeing it rotate from the top
let's look at rotate from to side as it
tries to make the ATP and push the
ingredients together these components
kind of bulge out a little bit okay as
everything comes together so the whole
structure changes and shifts during this
process of making ATP and one of the
things that makes this happen although
we can't visualize it in this movie is
the flow of protons through here
interacting with other components that
are invisible to us in this video
okay so once again how about an
experiment in this experiment which was
done by this wonderful Japanese lab
yoshida's lab what they did is they took
that whole machine and they stuck it on
a bead and they put that on a coverslip
in a microscope and they made it happy
so that it would actually spin but it's
too small to see right I mean we
wouldn't be able to see it if we didn't
modify it so on this gamma armature
remember the central component that's
spinning inside those six proteins they
attached a super long stick okay it's
completely straight and it's a giant
stick made of the protein called actin
okay it's a long actin filament and if
you imagine if I were the ATP's molecule
and I were here this stick they put on
him would go all the way out many many
streets away okay so it would be huge
and plus they made the stick so that it
has some ability for us to see it in
light okay so we can visualize this
stick now we can actually watch this
thing spin and it'll tell us how fast it
spins and what are the properties of
this thing while it spins so you're
going to see an f-18 epa's spin in real
time you move this
one of the things we do with these
experiments is we actually take frames
of these pictures and plot how often
that stick is at a certain degrees in
the circle and if you've been all this
information if you organize all the
information you see that on average it's
actually stopping at 100 we're pausing
at 120 degree increments so it's not a
completely uniform smooth cycle it's
kind of more like I'm not doing very
well I don't have a very good elbow that
will completely rotate but in any case
you get the idea that it's um it stops
in three places on average okay now
finally as it's getting late we're going
to say one final class of motors and
it's my favorite one actually because
it's what we do and these are nano
machines that tear apart DNA and RNA and
they're called helicase ha's and we need
these because they help to take care of
our genome remember all the information
that makes us us is inside our DNA in
the nucleus and that requires a lot of
care and we have our cells have to take
care of that DNA and they have to make
more of it when a cell divides so
there's a lot of work involved in taking
care of DNA and a lot of that is done by
the machines will see next now you're
going to see a movie of the replication
of DNA and what a helicase does
I don't think you guys can hear that up
there can you
this is the replication complex of DNA
what's what we're looking at here is the
machine that works when it's time to
copy our DNA the DNA to be copied is
coming in here and it's stripped apart
by this blue machine here this is the
helicase what she just said is it spins
the DNA as fast as a jet engine I think
that's 6p 6,000 rpm and the strands come
out this direction in this direction and
what's sitting on it the green things
are polymerizes these are the copying
machine to grab a single strand and
they'll make a new copy that's double
stranded DNA and it's coming out either
ends ok so this strands being opened
this strand is then once it's opened its
being copied ok so that blue part is the
helicase that i showed you before now
you're going to see it in green once
again Nature has used these multiples of
proteins and form them into rings to
make all kinds of molecular components
so this is what's known as a hexameric
EULA case it's made of six of these
proteins and what you what happens is
that one of the strands of DNA goes
through the middle of this thing the
other strand is spit out the side
because only one strand can fit through
the hole ok and these machines just like
the machines we showed before they also
burn ATP and they undergo changes in
conformation and that's what helps
propel them along the Strand now one of
the things I wanted to tell you about
when i showed you helicase is though is
that rotary motors and hela cases are
all made from this ancient protein
component it's called the recce fold
with a recce protein not this little
part hanging out here but this part this
is a very ancient protein building block
that must have written very very early
in evolution and it's been used
continually in the creation of almost
all the machines in our body so it's an
ancient construction module
so really the machines in our body are
built the same way that you would build
something out of Legos you have all
these bits of Lego all over your
playroom floor your bedroom floor but
many of them are the same type of
component and you when you take apart
your favorite thing you built out of
Lego you can build something else out of
the pieces it's exactly the same in
nature and the recce fold is the
ultimate natural Lego piece and let me
show you that so I can prove it to you
here is the hexameric helicase I showed
you and this is the wreck a protein what
we can do with computers is to lay these
proteins on top of each other and see
how well they match it's almost a
perfect match instructor so it's been
used repeatedly during evolution to
generate motors of different form and
function so let's just spin this around
so you can see that okay
okay so briefly one of the ways we study
HeLa cases is not just by lighting up
the molecules so we can see them in a
fancy camera one of the ways we study
those kinds of motors or motors that
exert force is to actually put them in
what we call a laser tweezer and that's
when we attach a DNA or RNA that the
helicase is going to work on to a bead
on one end and also on the other end and
then we hold the beads a constant
distance within a microscope in this
case in this drawing one of the beads is
held by suction on the end of a pipette
so it's just being held there by force
the other bead is being held in place by
a laser beam and we can hold them at a
perfectly constant force and then watch
as the helicase unravels the DNA and in
this particular case if this helicase
were to pull this strand of DNA apart it
would get longer and we could watch the
beads get farther and farther apart with
time and in that way we could watch one
molecule of a helicase at a time another
thing I should mention is that some
machines are also studied in a similar
way but they are turned and they're
attached to a bead that's magnetic and
then you take a magnet and you spin it
and then you can watch a rotary motor
deal with the force of this spinning
magnet now i'm going to show you an
experiment this is actually really
simple experiment all this is is a laser
tweezer that we built in the physics
department together with some students
in my department and some students in
physics and what you see here are two
beads and between them is a piece of DNA
and we're building this machine so we
can watch a helicase that we've been
working on in the lab and just this week
we finally got our laser tweezer
apparatus to work and what I'm going to
show you is how we can now see the laser
tweezer pull the beads apart and move
them around and this took about two
years of work to get this thing to work
so
this is what it looks like
okay so Margaret treas who was doing
this first started pulling on this bead
you can see its distance changing this
one's getting slightly perturbed and
folding pulled along a little less but
now this one is coming back she's
letting it relax she's going to pull on
it really hard this time really yank on
that guy you can see its distance change
and now she's really pretty sure she's
captured the beads so she's yanking on
it back and forth and it's moving up and
down like a yo-yo okay so in the next
set of experiments which we haven't done
yet so I can't show them to you we'll
put our nanomachine on there and do the
same experiment and see how the helicase
changes all of these things that we just
observed but I thought you might like
this because this is data that's only
about three days old and it's always fun
to see what scientists are actually
doing right now so that's what we have
on that okay so today we've watched
three kinds of nature's nanomachines
molecular motors in action we watched a
walking cargo motor that carries all
kinds of things on a highway made-up
tubulin and its name is Kai neeson we
watched an energy-producing motor that
spins around so we looked and we even
watched ourselves a molecule of f-18
epa's and we looked at a tracking motor
that unzips DNA and it's called a
helicase so we've seen three different
examples of things in nature that are
basically nanomachines all of them burn
ATP and most of them are actually made
out of the same sort of LEGO pieces that
they just have different shapes and
functions and I want to close by
thanking all the people who made this
possible my talk today benefited from
the help of a bunch of my colleagues
Kevin Keating was a grad student in
computational biology Sean Taylor who is
a graduate student in molecular
biophysics Margaret treas and Andrew
who are grad students in physics and we
have very nice friends who do a lot of
this kind of work at university of
illinois dr. TJ ha and dr. Yan Cheng law
who gave us great ideas for movies and
who also sent us some data but
especially today we want to thank the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute because
it is doing a wonderful job bringing
science to the public through animations
and other resources and this is their
website if you can manage to copy any of
that down and and please make use of all
the things that hhmi is doing so anyway
thanks for your attention and to our
organizers also